handing out iodine tablets in the city
of zaparisia offering some protection in
the event of a radiation leak from
europe's largest nuclear power plant 55
kilometers away
a team of international atomic energy
agency inspectors has now arrived in
ukraine on route to the nuclear site
occupied by russian soldiers since march
this is an extremely unusual event i
don't think there's been anything quite
like it in history nuclear engineer
robert kelly led similar inspection
missions in iraq in the 1990s we were in
a position to go in with
the might of the coalition behind us
in this case they're going in as guests
i believe of the russians maybe the
russians and ukrainians
and i think that they might very well be
prohibited from doing everything that
they want to do
both sides in the war are accusing the
other of shelling the plant new
independent satellite images appear to
show a hole in the roof of a building
perilously close to a reactor 100 meters
away russia publishing these photos
blaming ukraine experts say the risk of
any meltdown event is low and limited to
about 40 kilometers around the plant but
nearby concerns still remain high the
nuclear inspection mission to zaparisia
begins as ukraine announces the start of
its long-awaited counter-offensive in
the south including in the neighboring
carson region after months of
near-stalemate analysts believe this
push using weapons from the west could
determine where the war goes next if
ukraine is able to liberate hassan that
will be very important to the overall
war effort uh if russia is able to hold
on to the city and the region it could
act as a gateway for a future russian
offensive to try to take the key city of
odessa which could effectively cut
ukraine off in the black sea meanwhile
the british ministry of defense says
vladimir putin is now bypassing his
minister of defense sergey shoigu and
dealing directly with commanders if true
a further sign russia's invasion is not
going to plan redmond shannon global
news london